ثم طابت اوقاتكم ساعه اخباريه من العربيه
اهلا بكم نبداها بابرز العناوين
قتلوا الجرحى بقصف صاروخيه للحرس الثوري
الايراني على مواقع في اربيل والسليمانيه
شمال العراق
تركيا توقف 23 مشتبها في انفجار تقسيمها
وزير الداخليه يحمل حزب العمال
الكردستانيه المسؤوليه
العربيه ترصد معاناه سكان كيف بسبب انقطاع
الكهرباء جراء القصف الروسيه للبنى
التحتيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يتجه لفرض المزيد من
العقوبات على ايران وماكرون يجددوا وصفه
تظاهرات بالثوره
حياكم الله استهدف الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
مواقع على الاكراد في شمال العراق بصواريخ
ما ادى الى مقتلعه شخص واصابه 10 على
الاقل وذكر مراسل العربيه ان الحرس
الثوريه استهدف عبر ضربات جويه وصاروخيه
مقارا تابعه للحزب للاحزاب الكرديه
المعارضه للنظام الايراني في بلده كوين
سجد شرقه اربيل ومنطقه زر كويز في
السليمانيه واكد قائم مقام قضاء كوين سجق
طارق الحيدري ان مقرات الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستانيه الايرانيه المعارض استهدفت
بقصفا صاروخيه
من اربيل عبد السلام
البرواري النائب السابق في البرلمان
الكردستاني عن الحزب الديمقراطيه
الكردستاني ينضم الينا من اربيل اهلا بك
سيد عبد السلام يعني بدايه ما هي الرساله
التي توجهها ايران الى العراق عبر هذا
القصف
الاخوان المسلمين
الى العراق
[موسيقى]
خلال اسبوع كان هناك حديث عن احتماليه
قيام ايران بعمليات قصف صاروخي على
كردستان وعلى السعوديه
بالتاكيد الايرانيون اليوم
سيبحثون عن اضعف نقطه
هذا الاحزاب المعارضه
اللاجئين الذين المنتخب
على وشك الانفجار احتجاج على استشهاد
محسى ميني تحول الى احتجاج جماهيري في كل
ارجاء ايران نحن نسمع نرى همم
شعارات واضحه سقوط
من الملالي تسقط الديكتاتوريه اذا كانت
قبل همم
انطلاق عمليات عسكريه من حدود كردستان
العراق او دعم عسكري من الاحزاب المعرضه
لما يجري في كردستاني ايران في الحقيقه
الان الوضع همم
تحول الى او اكثر من ذلك هناك احتجاجات في
شرخ ايران وفي طهران وفي همم قريب حدود
الافغانيه اذا المبرر الحقيقي مهما كان
ليس له اي ارضيه واقعيه هل معنى ذلك انها
همم طهران تريد الضغط على الاكراد خاصه
بعد هذا القصف لي تخفيف حده التظاهرات في
الداخل الايراني وبالتالي العراق كيف
سيتصرف مع هكذا وضع
الحكومه المركزيه
انا شخصيا انا كررت في اكثر من مقام حكومه
اقليم كردستان ليس لديها لا القدره يعني
امكانيه في ان تدخل في صراع مباشر عسكري
مع ايران حمايه همم سلامه المواطنين ولا
ساكنين في الاراضي العراقيه هي مسؤوليه
الدوله العراقيه
ولكن تعرف يعني منذ سنوات حتى الحكومه
العراقيه انا اعترف حتى لو كانت العقيده
ان تتخذ موقف اكثر الشده من الذي رايناه
سابقا تجاه ايراني
احد الاسباب الرئيسيه هو وجود سواء موالي
يعني لها تاثير كبير على القرار الرسمي
فين في العراق يعني في حكومه
شاهدنا صعيدا لقيامهم
استدعاء السفير اصدار بيان استنكار التحدث
عن نقل الموضوع الى المحافظ الدولي الامم
المتحده حتى هذا لم تكن تقوم به الحكومه
السابقه لذلك
سيستمر
هذا الاعتداءات
وضحيهم اهاليه صور الشخص الذي توفى
استشهاد
يعني
جرح ثم استشهد
اعتقدح الى كردستان العراق كامله 30 سنه
في القصف الذي حدث بالونات بالمسيرات في
منطقه سليمانيه لم يكن هناك همم يعني همم
اي اثار الروح همم يعني بشريني عن نفس
المنطقه
السابقه وهي تغتصبه مهجوره كانت
كوريا في شرق محافظه
اربيل فكان هناك كما اشار تقريركم جرحه
وشهيد من اربيل عبد السلام مع البرواري
النائب السابق في البرلمان الكردستاني عن
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني شكرا جزيلا
لك
اعلن يا وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان سولو
اعتقال الشخص المسؤول عن انفجار امس في
شارع الاستقلال بمنطقه تقسيم وقال الوزير
التركي انه تم توقيف 22 شخصا مشتبهم
حسب العمال الكردستانيه بالمسؤوليه عن
الانفجار الذي اسفر عن سته اتلاع على
الاقل واصابه العشرات في اسطنبول
واوضح ان جميع القتل السته في الانفجار
مواطنوننا اتراك
قبل قليل تم اعتقال الشخص الذي نفذ الهجوم
امس من قبل فرق شرطه اسطنبول كانت الشرطه
اعتقلت حوالي 21 شخصا اخرين مشتبه بهم
اكتشفنا ايضا ان تعليمات الهجوم جاءت من
مدينه كوباني شمال سوريا كما راينا ان
الانتحاري قد مر عبر مدينه عفرين
[موسيقى]
معنى من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان زين
كلو زيدان اهلا بك ما الجديد لديك
حوالي الساعه السابعه الا ربع بتوقيت
بتوقيت المحلي او التوقيت اسطنبول تم
افتتاح شارع الاستقلال امام المره بعد
اغلاقه همم طيله الليله الماضيه وبعد ايضا
اغلاقه بعد الانفجار مباشره ضلها مغلقا
حتى صباح هذا اليوم في الساعه 7:00 الا
ربع فتحت السلطات التركيه شارع الاستقلال
امام الماره وهو يشهد حركه شبه اعتياديه
في مثل هذا التوقيت يكون هناك بعض
الازدحام هناك فعلا بعض الازدحام في بعض
المناطق في شارع الاستقلال نحن نتواجد
الان عادل امام في المكان الذي جرى فيه
الانفجار الان يمكن مشاهده طبعا هناك
ازدحام من الصحفيين لا شك لكن يمكن مشاهده
همم هذا المحل الذي جرى همم بالضبط امامه
الانفجار الواجهات او الزجاج دمر بالكامل
وتحطهم بالكامل همم ايضا هناك همم
بعض المواطنين الاتراك يضعون الورود في
مكان الانفجار لكن لاحظنا اليوم في جوله
صباحيه قبل ان نصل همم هذا المكان في شارع
الاستقلال الجميع المقاعد التي كانت
موجوده في شارع الاستقلال قد ازيلت
بالكامل من قبل السلطات تركيا قبل اعاده
افتتاح شارع الاستقلال كما تعلم معادل ان
القنبله او المراه التي وضعت القبه وضعتها
تحت مقعد همم تحت مقعد في شارع الاستقلال
ثم انفجر بعد مغادره
وزير الداخليه فجر اليوم قال
بانفذ العمليه الرجل هل هناك تضارب هل
هناك اشتراك في هذه العمليه
لا يوجد تضارب همم نعم لا يوجد تضارب وزير
داخليه كان يتحدث وقال الشخص الذي نفذ
العمليه تم اعتقاله اا لكن هو لم يقصد ان
منفذ العمليه هو رجل همم الفيديوهات التي
نشرتها فيما بعد مديريه الامن في اسطنبول
نشرت اعتقال امراه في شقه في احد احياء
اسطنبول همم بالاضافه طبعا الى اشخاص
اخرين كانوا معها في نفس الشقه التركيز
كان على هذه الامراه وعلى ما يبدو ان هذه
الامراه التي هي من وضعت القنبله همم في
شارع الاستقلال طيب خلفيات المجتبه بهم
يعني وصل العدد الى 22 او 23 همم بالتالي
خلفياتهم هل هم اكراد ماذا عنهم او هم من
سهل وصول الامراه
نعم لا شك ان المنفذ الذي حمل القنبله
وضعها في شارع الاستقلال حسب حسب المعطيات
وحسب التصريحات الرسميه هي الامراه التي
جرعت قالها اما المجموعه الاخرى هي لا شك
ال ال هي التي وفرت الدعم اللوجستي لهذه
المراه لم يتم الكشف عن جنسيات الاخرين
لكن همم الاتهام كان واضحا لحزب العمال
الكردستاني والفرع السوري كما يتصفه انقره
حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي في سوريا وان
خلفيه او التعليمات جاءت من عين العرب همم
في شمال اا شرق سوريا لذلك طبعا همم همم
خلفيه الامراه ربما تكون سوريا كرديه من
عين العرب لكن حتى الان همم لم يتم
الافصاح عن هذا الموضوع هي مجرد تكهونات
من قبل بعض المصادر غير الرسميه لكن
بالعموم الاتهام موجهه رسميا الى حزب
العمال الكردستاني وايضا كان هناك من ضمن
السياق التصريحات وزير الداخليه كان هناك
تهديدات للحزب وداعمي وممولي سواء في
تركيا او في اكثر من منطقه مجاوره
زيدان همم زنك له مراسل العربيه من
اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
اوكرانيات تتهم روسيا بارتكابي جرائم حرب
في خيرسون
حياكم الله اذا سنذهب الى هذه الصور
المباشره للوصول القاده الى جزيره باليه
التي تستعد لانطلاق فعاليات قمه قاده
مجموعه العشرين بمشاركه 19 دوله الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ودول ضيوف الشرف
وبالتالي هناك العديد من القضايا التي
سيتم مناقشتها ابرز ربما هناك ايضا قمه
تجمع الرئيسين الامريكي
والصيني في هذه القمه قمه ال 20 كانت
اندونيسيا طلبات من الاوروبيين ولا
امريكيين وكذلك اليابانيين تخفيف حده
الخطاب لديهم همم
ربما الخروج ببيان توافق عليه روسيا في
نهايه هذا الاجتماع
الانباء تشير الى غياب الرئيس الروسي الذي
ماربوتون عن هذه القمه ولكن قد وفق
المستشار الالماني قد يكون هناك همم
مفاجات اللحظه الاخيره من عوده الرئيس
الروسي الى حضور هذه القمه
اذا تتناول القمه الجي 28 او قمه العشرين
التي تقام على مداريه يومين الخامس عشر
وسادس عشر ملفات الزراعه مكافحه الفساد
الاقتصاد الرقميه وكذلك الطاقه المستدامه
والاستثمار ايضا التوظيف والصحه والبيئه
والتنميه وكذلك التجاره وانظمه الدفع
الرقميه وغيرها من الملفات بالاضافه الى
الملفات السياسيه
نكمل معكم النشرات قالت نيوزيلندا انها
سترسل 66 فردا اضافيا من قوات الدفاع الى
بريطانيا للمساعده في تدريب الجنود
الاوكرانيين مع استمرار الحربي في
اوكرانيا ول لنيوزلندا حاليا فريق مكون من
120 فردا من قوه الدفاع نيوزلنديه للتدريب
الاوكرانيين في بريطانيا ولكن كان من
المقرر انتهاء هذه المهمه
اكتشفوا اكثر من 400 جريمه حرب روسيه
وعثروا على جثه جنود ومدنيون في عده اماكن
بمنطقه خرسانه التي سحبت منها روسيا منذ
يومين
سليتش برجراف
اكثر من 400 جريمه حرب روسيا وعثر على جثث
لمدنيين وعسكريين في منطقه خرسون خلف
الجيش الروسي وراءه الوحشيه نفسها كما هو
الحال في مناطق اخرى من بلدنا حيث تمكن من
الغزو سوف نقدم للعداله كل قاتل دون ادنى
القتال في المنطقه
بشرقي اوكرانيا كان شديدا كما كان في
الايام الاخيره دون توقف واضاف انها مستوى
الهجمات الروسيه لم ينخفض وان مستوى صمود
قوته وشجاعتهم
القتال في منطقه دنيسك عنيف كما كان في
الايام السابقه وتيره الهجمات الروسيه لا
تتراجع مستوى مرونه جنودنا وشجاعتهم هو
الاكبر نحن لا نسمح لهم باختراق دفاعنا
اشكر كل محاربين على هذا
استهداف القوات الروسيه للبنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه لا سيما منشات الطاقه الحيويه
يهدد ما يقرب من اربعه ملايين شخص في
العاصمه كيف بالاجراء القسري كحل اخيرا
نتيجتها ازمه انقطاع الكهرباء بشكل متكرر
والتي ستتفاق مع حلولي فصل الشتاء
المعاناه تزداد والازمه تتفاقم في جميع
المدن الاوكرانيه لاسيما في العاصمه كيف
نتيجه استهدف الروس للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه
والتي اصبحت غير قادره على تغطيه حاجه
الاستهلاك المحلي نهيك عن توقف صادر
الكهربائي الى الاتحاد الاوروبي كيف ام
مدن الروس كما يحلو للشعوب الصليبيه
مناداتها تغرق في ظلام دامس ويعيش مواطنها
ايام قاسيه ويتوقعون شتاء اقصى فلاد يحاول
ان يتكيف مع هذا الوضع الماساوي وان يجد
حلولا بديلا ويتمنى ان لا يضطر الى
مغادرتي
في النهار نقوم بشحنه لاستخدامه عندما
تقطع الكهرباء الكهرباء تقطع اربع ساعات
وتعاد لمده اربع ساعات اذا حدث وخرجت
الشبكه عن التغطيه تماما فلن يبقى لنا
شموع اما هذه الصيدليه فهي احدى صيدليات
شبكه صيدليات اوكرانيا الكهرباء مقطوعه في
المنطقه وبالتالي ايضا مقطوعه في الصيدليه
ولكنها تعمل
بالمولد سندخل ونتحدث اليهم ونعرف كيف هو
الوضع هنا في الصيدليه
الدراسات
الكهرباء
ويتاثر قطاع المواصلات مما يفاقم الازمه
ويضاعف من معاناه المواطنين ويؤثر على
مداخلهم
للحلاقه نحن نعمل الان بحسب جدول انقطاع
الكهرباء
التي تعمل عن طريق الشاحن المتنقل
انقطاع الكهرباء يتكرر خلال اليوم عده
مرات تتوقف فيها الحياه لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه المواطنون قادرون على التاقلم مع
الامر الا ان الشتاء يزحف شيئا فشيئا
ودرجات الحراره ستنخفض حتى تصبح تحت الصفر
وعندها لن يفيد المواطنين تفهمهم وقد تلجا
الدوله لما وصفته بالحل الاخير وهو عمليه
اجلاء واسعه النطاق حتى لا يتجمد الناس
لقناتي العربيه والحدث حذف عادل كيف
معنا من دونناسكم مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر رائد اهلا بك يعني كان هناك حديث
عن اشتداد القتال حيث انت ضعنا في تفاصيل
الصوره
عادل نعم يعني تحتدم المعارك على جميع
المحاور ليس في دنباس وحدها وانما في
الجنوب الاوكراني ايضا او الجنوب الروسي
حيث ان القوات الاوكرانيه التي سيطرت على
خرسون تقصف باستمرار
بلدات على الضفه الشماليه حيث انتقال
الجيش الروسي من نهر النيل برو بالفعل
هناك ايضا تصريحات
لسلطات زاباروجه همم مقاطعه زاباروجه
المجاوره الى ان اوكرانيا تحشد اكثر من
40,000 مقاتل في هذا المحور للانتقال خلال
اسبوعين الى محطه زبرج لابد من التنويه
هنا عادل هنا ان محطه زباروجه ان انا
نوويه تقع على جانب الايمن من النهر اي اا
الناحيه الاخرى من انسحاب الجيش الروسي
ولابد انه هناك بالفعل همم تطورات جديده
بعد سيطره الجيش الاوكراني على مدينه
خرسون ربما يكون همم او تكون المرحله
القادمه هي مرحله المحطه النوويه في
زاباروجه اما على محور دانيت ودمبس هو
فعلا الاكثر سخونه منذ الصباح الباكر
والطيران يحلق في سماء المنطقه طيران
الروسي
وافقنا على اصوات الانفجارات وايضا ال-
القصف الشديد المتبادل من الطرفين همم
تحاول القوات المواليه لروسيا التقدم في
شمال غرب همم المقاطعه حيث مدينه
ايضا سيطرت هذه القوات المواليه لروسيا
بشكل كامل على مدينه مارس همم قريبه من
مدينه باخمت في ايضا شمال غرب المقاطعه
همم هذه المدينه استراتيجيه لقربها من
مدينه التي يقاتل فيها الجيش الروسي قوات
باغنا الخاصه وهي همم يمكنها
تعزز او تمد القوات التي تقاتل هناك
بامدادات العسكريه ايضا هناك المحور
الجنوبي همم يعني داهمت القوات الاوكرانيه
يعني بهجوم عكسي القوات الروسيه التي
سيطرت منذ يومين على مدينه او بلده
بابلوكا بالقرب من اجلدار جنوب دانيت لكن
الدفاع الروسيه اشارت الى سد هذا الهجوم
وتكميد الجانب الاوكراني خسائر كبيره يبقى
المحور الاهم وهو المثلث الناري حيث
الايمان وكبيان واثباتها حيث تمركز القوات
الروسيه بعد انسحابها من لمان الى همم
مدينه كريم تقول الدفاع الروسيه ايضا انها
احبطت عديد من الهجمات الاوكرانيه وكبدتهم
خسائر كبيره بالعتاب والجنود عادل شكرا
جزيلا لمراسل العربيه
ذكركم بان الخبر العاجل ان عدد المشتبه
بهم في انفجار اسطنبول وصل الى 46 شخصا تم
اعتقالهم حتى الان قالت وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه جنتيلن ان الولايات المتحده
ستفرض عقوبات جديده على شبكه عابره للحدود
تضم افرادا وشركات تعمل على شراء تقنيات
عسكريه للجهود الحربيه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
الصحفيين على هامشي قمه مجموعه العشرين في
بالي باندونيسيا ان العقوبات تستهدف 14
فردا 84 28 كيانا ورفضت الوزيره الامريكيه
الادلاء بتفاصيل عن اماكن تواجدهم لكنها
اضافت انه من المقرر صدور اعلان في وقت
لاحق اليوم
قبل ذلك يا دعاء الرئيس الاندونيسيه جوكو
وديدو وعدد من السياسيين الاندونيسيين
القاده الغربيين لخفض حده خطاباتهم التي
وصفوها بالمعاديه لروسيا في قمه مجموعه
العشرين ووفقا لصحيفه بوليتكو يتعرض
المسؤولون الامريكيون والاوروبيون
والاستراليون واليابانيون لضغوط من نظرهم
الاندونيسيين ولا سينما رئيس ودودو لاظهار
المرونه والتفكير في استخدام خطاب اقل حده
لضمان موافقه موسكو على بيان في اعقابي
الاجتماعي
تعقد الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده اليوم
الجلسه الحادي عشر تحت بنده متحدون من اجل
السلام بطلب من اوكرانيا وستقدم كيف مشروع
قرار يطالب روسيا بتقديم تعويضات جراء
الخراب والخسائر التي حلت باوكرانيا
يلتقي وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بروكسل حيث من المقرر ان يفرضوا المزيد من
العقوبات على ايران على خلفيه القمع
المنهجي للاحتجاجات وقال دبلوماسياني
لرويترز ان الحزمه الجديده ستشهد 31
تصنيفا لانتهاكات حقوق الانسان تستهدف
الافراد والقيانات وتشمل فرض حضرا على
الاصول وتجميد السفر كما ستكون حرب روسيا
في اوكرانيا موضوع رئيسا اخرا للمناقشه
فبرا
من هناك انضم الينا مراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريديه نور الدين اهلا بك يعني
لنبدا اولا بالملفات الايراني ما هي طبيعه
هذه العقوبات التي ستفرض وابرز الكيانات
او الافراد على الاقل ان كان هناك تسريب
لاسمائهم
حزمه العقوبات الاضافيه التي ستصدر ظهرا
اليوم
ستشمل عدد كبيرا من الكيانات والمسؤولين
31 مسؤولا وكيانا هم بالاساس من كبار
المسؤولين في الحرس الثوري والملشيات
المتصله به والتي تقوموا وتتولى حمله
القمع المنهج ضد الاحتجاجات السلميه هذه
الحزمه من العقوبات هي الثانيه في ظرف شهر
همم اتخذ الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات السابقه
في شهر اكتوبر وكلها والعقوبات كافه
تستهدفه المسك كبار المسؤولين في الحاله
الثوريه الايراني في بريشيات البسيج وفي
شرطه ايران الاخلاقيه وربما في القائمه
التي تنشروا في الجريده الرسميه ظهر اليوم
ايضا بعض المسؤولين المغتصدين بانظمه
القضاء والسجون ستكون فرض حاضر على السفر
وعلى الاصول وتجميد السفر ايضا
وبالتالي هل من الممكن ان تزيد ستدخل حيز
التنفيذ تقليدا هي هي نفسها هي حظر الدخول
للاتحاد الاوروبي هي تجميد الاصول هي حضره
التعاون بين الاشخاص
والمؤسسات الاوروبيه مع تلك الكيانات في
ايران هناك اسئله ترددت منذ يوم الجمعه
حتى صباح اليوم ان هذه العقوبات المتكرره
من الشهر الماضي واليوم وربما ايضا في
المستقبل الى حد الان لم تشمل بعد الحرس
الثوري الايراني
اتخاذ هذه العقوبات الحزمه الحزمه الا
تؤثر هاتر عقبات نهايه على ما تبقى من
حظوظ الاحياء الاتفاق النوويه ردا على هذا
السؤال جوزه بريل في صفته مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه والذي تحدث يوم امس مع وزير
الخارجيه الايراني امير عبد الحياني قال
ان الاتفاق النووي لا يزال يمثل السبيل
الوحيد للح دون تزود ايران بالسلاح النووي
ولكن يبدو ان هذا ان دخول ايران في حرب
اوكرانيا بطريقه او باخرى يعني من خلال
تزويدها روسيا بالمسيرات سواء كان قبل
الحرب او في غضون الحرب تمثل مصدر قلق
كبير جدا بالنسبه لي الاوروبيين وخاصه
عندما تحدث وزير خارجيه تسويه صباح اليوم
عن ان دعم اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله بالذات
ياخذ الاولويه على اي اتفاق اخر حتى وان
كان الاتفاقنا وبالتالي انعم هناك عدد همم
يعني الدول الاوروبيه همم غاضبه جدا من
موقف ايران بدعمها لروسيا طبعا هناك حمله
ممنهجه وهناك التصعيد في هذه العقوبات
وتوقع ان يتم تنسيق العقوبات التي يتخذها
الاتحاد الاوروبي معه العقوبات او مع
الدول الاخرى التي تلتقي مع الاتحاد في
همم في همم في المقارنه بالحاليه تجاه
ايران سنرى ذلك في نهايه الاجتماع عندما
سيعقد زي البوريل همم مؤتمره صحفي همم في
نهايه النهار بالتاكيد هو نحن ايضا سننتظر
معك لكن لابد ان اسالك ولو كان باختصار عن
الملف الروسي الاوكراني كيف سيكون النقاش
على عجاله اذا تكرمت
نعم انه هناك اخبار طيبه حسب كلامه تاتي
من الجبهه الاوكرانيه قال ان الاتحاد
الاوروبيه يعني ينتهجوا هذه المقاربه دعم
اوكرانيا على جميع الاسعده السياسيه
والعسكريه والماليه ثانيا مواصله الضغط
على رؤوس من خلال العقوبات او من خلال
العزيزه دوليه والتواصل مع العالم مثل ما
يحدث في همم في مجموعه 20 هذا الاسبوع
شكرا جزيلا لمراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريقين من بروكسل
من جانبه جدد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون ووصف الاحتجاجات في ايران للمره
الثانيه بالثوره ماكرون اضاف ان العقوبات
المفروضه على النظام الايراني جبال تتاثى
يتاثر بها الشعب الايراني واضاف ان افضل
العقوبات هي تلك التي تستهدف المقربين من
النظام الايراني هذا وكانت فرنسا واجهت في
وقت سابقا انتقادات للحكومه الايرانيه
متهمه اياها بالقيام بممارسات
الديكتاتوريه على خلفيات احتجاجها لسبعه
مواطنين فرنسيين واستضده واضح في العلاقات
بين البلدين
دعانوا شقاء في ايران لتنظيم تظاهرات
وتجمعات امام مقابر المدن الايرانيه اليوم
الاثنين لاحياء ذكرى سنويه الاحتجاجات
نوفمبر من العام 2019 الداميه واعلنت
مجموعه شباب احياء مدينه كركان الشماليه
ايران اعلنت تنظيمه تظاهرات في ساحات
المدينه الرئيسه معتبره انما اسمته
باستمرار الكفاح الميداني ضروره حيويه في
غضون ذلك دعى طلاب الجامعات الى استمرار
التظاهرات تنديدا لقمع الشرطه والغاء
ايقاف الطلاب من الدراسه والافراج عن
المعتقلين
[موسيقى]
ياباني
قبل لقاء المرتقب مع نظيره الصيني
حياكم الله اعلن البيت الابيض ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايد ان يريد اعاده فتحي
قنوات للحوار مع بكين خلال اجتماعهم مع
نظيره الصينيه
محادثات ثنائيه مرتقبه في جزيره بالي
الاندلسيه المستضيفه لقمه مجموعه العشرين
البيت الابيض اكد ان سيسعى الى تحديد
ضمانات مع نظيره الصينيه في ظل التوترات
بين البلدين والبلدان على خلاف حول قضايا
تتراوح من التجاره الى حقوق الانسان في
منطقه
الصينيه والى وضع تايوان
معنا من القاهره صحفيه عامر تمام مع
المتخصصه في الشان الصينيه سيد عامر اهلا
بك هل ستنجح الولايات المتحده عبر جو
بايدم بفتح هذه القنوات خاصه ان اليوم
الكل متمسك برايه وهناك كما ترى الصين
زياره بيلوسي وغيرها من المسؤولين
الامريكيين الى تايوان هي محاولات استفزاز
نعم
عقد مثل هذه القمه هو نجاح بكل تاكيد
الرئيس لم يلتقي الرئيس وجها لوجه منذ
انتخابه ربما هذا الموضوع اثار الكثير من
سوء الفهم في العلاقات بين البلدين لذلك
مجرد ان يلتقي الرئيسان وجها لوجه هو نجاح
همم ربما همم قبل ان تبدا او قبل ان يتم
مناقشه القضايا التي يتم طرحها اما
بالنسبه للقضايا الهامه التي سيتم طرحها
همم ليس من المتوقع ولا من المطلوب من هذه
القمه ان تحل همم او همم تصل لحلول لكل
القضايا الشركه بين البلدين لان هذه
القضايا من المستحيل ان تحل ولكن على
الاقل ان يتم الاتفاق على همم ضمانات او
على وضع خطوط حمراء ربما الخطوط الحمراء
موجوده وكل يعرف ال- ال- الخطوط الحمراء
للطرف الاخر ولكن ما هو مطلوب في هذه
الفتره هو
وضع تعريف لهذه الخطوط الحمراء حتى لا يتم
او لا يوجد سوء فهم بين البلدين الصين
لديها خطوط حمراء والولايات المتحده لديها
خطوط حمراء الصين الخطوط الحمراء تبدا بي
تايوان تبدا بقضايا حقوق الانسان تبدا
بعسكره بحر الصين الجنوبي بكثير من الامور
نعم طبعا يعني حتى في الملف يعني التوتر
موجود في الملف السياسي ولكن ايضا حتى في
الملف الاقتصادي هناك بابونج شاسع بين
الاراء بين الطرفين وبالتالي عن اي قنوات
نتحدث يمكن ان تتواصل او تتوصل اليها هذه
القمه ولت تقريبا وجهات النظر
نعم هناك
مخاوف صينيه خلال الفتره الماضيه من ان
يسبب وصول
الجمهوريون لاغلبيه مجلس النواب الى وجود
المزيد من
الضغط على الصين او وجود ضغط على العلاقات
الصينيه والمزيد من السوق لذلك الصين تريد
ان تتفهم مع الرئيس بايدم بشان قضايا على
وجه التحديد وهي ال- القضيه الاهم بالنسبه
للصين قضيه تايونيه هي تريد ان همم لا يتم
التصعيد في هذه القضيه لا يتم ارسال رسائل
همم من شانها تزكيه او فكره استقلال
الجزيره همم هناك همم همم سوء للعلاقات او
همم النتائج سلبيه للعلاقات في العلاقات
بين البادين بسبب زياره بيلوسي هذه القيمه
ربما يتم همم حاله هذا الموضوع ويتم فتح
القنوات التي تم اغلاقها بسبب هذه الزياره
ايضا هناك رغبه من جانب الصين
لازاله الحواجز همم الجمركيه التي فرضتها
الولايات المتحده اداره ترامب على الصين
بما يشكل تسهيل لعمليه سلاسل ال- ال- ال-
الامداد ويشكل همم همم فائده للاقتصاد
العالمي لذلك هناك قضايا اقتصاديه قضايا
سياسيه ولكن الابرز هو القضايا مساله
الحواجز همم الجمركيه والابرز ايضا مساله
تايوان بالنسبه للصين نعم شكرا جزيلا يا
صحفي عامر تماما المتخصصه في الشان الصيني
من القاهره
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاستراليه انطونيا
البنزين بانه سيجري محادثات مع الرئيس
الصينيين في جزيره جبال الاندونيسيه وذلك
في اول اجتماع على مستوى القاده بين
البلدين بعد فتور في العلاقات دامه لسنوات
وقال رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي لدى وصوله
الى بالي ان اللقاء سيتضمن بحث جميع
الملفات العالقه
اوضح حتى سفاره البريطانيه في اندونيسيا
ان رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشي سوناتا
يدعو خلال مشاركته في قمه العشرين الى
اتخاذ اجراءات عالميه منسقه لمواجهه
التضخم وعدم الاستقرار الاقتصادي العالمي
واكدت السفاره ان سوناك سيستغل قمه
العشرين في دعوه روسيا الى انهاء الحرب
مضيفه تواجه عزله دوليه بسبب حملتها
العنيفه في اوكرانيا
هكذا رئيس مجلس سياده سودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهان الموضيه في اصلاح القوات المسلحه
والشرطه الى انه لن يسمح لاي جهه بالهيمنه
على الشرطه او
الاصلاح السلطه
واحده على قوات الشرطه وتهميش وزاره
الداخليه وتركيزا ده كلام بيقول مقتنعين
بان الشرطه يجب انها تكون شرطه محترفه
شرطه
انا شغال في العمليات انا شغال في
العمليات انا شغال في الجمارك شغال في
الجمارك عشان اقدر اجوي عمليه واجود واجبي
قبل ذلك اعتقل الامن السوداني العميد
الصوارمي خالد سعد المتحدث السابق باسم
القوات المسلحه في عهد الرئيس السابق عمر
البشير من امام منزله في العاصمه الخرطوم
تاتي عمليه الاعتقال بعد ساعات من اعلان
الصوارمي تشكيله قوه المسلحه من متقاعدي
الجيش تحت اسم قوات كيان الوطن العسكريه
من جانبيه رفض الصوارميه الكشف عن قوته
واصفا اياها بالضخمه واوضح ان هدفها الغاء
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه سلام جوبا وتمثيل
الولايات التي لم تكن لها قوات عسكريه
وانا في الصوارمي موجوده اي صدام من مع
القوات النظاميه مشددا على عدم الدخول في
اي مواجهه مع تلك القوه
معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه محمد عثمان
محمد اهلا بك هل يعني هل هناك مزيد عن هذا
الاعتقال لصور من خالد سعد وما هي هذه
القوه
نعم اهلا بك عادل صباح الخير طبعا هذا
الاعتقال كان متوقع من قبل البعض على
اعتبار ان يعني المؤسسه العسكريه تريد ان
ترسل رسائل واضحه ان انها لا ترغب في اي
همم وجود عسكري مخالف للمنظومه الرسميه
اول منظومه الاساسيه وهي الجيش والدعم
السريع وايضا قوات الشرطه لعل هذه الرساله
هي كانت الرساله همم لكثير من التيارات
العسكريه وايضا الحركات همم العسكريه هنا
ايضا لا بد من الاشاره الى ان الاعتقال
كان في الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا اليوم
من قبل القوه من الاستخبارات العسكريه
وذلك على خلفيه تشكيل هذه القوه من قبل
اللواء معاش الصواريخ خالد سعد الذي شغل
منصب الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
في نهائيات عهد الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
طبعا هنالك دوافع تحدث عنها
الصور من خالد سعد من خلال المؤتمر الصحفي
الذي عقده امس وهو الذي اعلن من خلاله
التشكيل هذه القوه قوه كيان الوطن هو
ينادي بان تكون هنالك تنميه متوازنه في
كافه اقاليم السودان اسوه
بالتنميه التي حدثت في اعقب اتفاقيه
السلام هنالك في دارفور وايضا في النيل
الازرق وكذلك ايضا في منطقه جنوب كردفان
هنالك من يقول بان يعني هذه الاقاليم حصلت
على ما حصلت عليه اثر اتفاقيه جوبا للسلام
وايضا هم يريدون ان تكون هنالك تنميه
متوازنه هذه الاقاليم التي حصلت على هذه
المكاسب ونسبه من قسمه الثروه والسلطه
كانت بدافع انها تمتلك قوات وحركات مسلحه
تعمل في دارفور وفي النيل الازرق وكذلك في
منطقه جنوب كردفان وان هذا الامر لا ينعكس
بصوره
في بقيه الاقاليم هم يريدون تشكيل قوه
عسكريه حتى يتم الضغط على المنظومه
الحاكمه باحداث تنميه متوازنه في بقيه
الاقاليم نحن نتحدث عن اقليم الوسط
والشمال والشرق وكذلك ايضا في المناطق
مناطق كردوفان وغيرها ايضا من المناطق
التي التي يعتبرونها انها مناطق هي مناطق
مهمشه ولم تاخذ حظها من الثروه والسلطه
شكرا جزيلا محمد عثمان مراسل العربيه من
الخرطوم
الى ناصر دائما والاقتصاد اليك ناصر شكرا
عادل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا السوق السعوديه
تعمق خسارها الان متراجعه بقرابه ال 41
نقطه المئويه مؤشر يقترب من مستواه
ال11000
نقطه ايضا الاسواق الباقيه بالمجمل تشهد
بعض التراجعات لكن النسب تبقى محدوده
اربعه اشهر نقطه المئويه في دبي في ابو
ظبي وتراجعات في قطر بسبعه اعشار استقرار
على مؤشر الكويت الاول لماذا التراجعات في
السوق السعوديه لانه لاحظ مجموعه تداول
السهم الاكثر نشاطا من حيث القيمه الان
يتداول دون مستويات ال 180 ريال نتذكر
واياكم انه بعد جرس يوم الخميس همم جرس
الاغلاق كان هناك الاعلام من صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه عن تخارجه من 10%
اضافيه في مجموعه تداول معها همم عند
السعر الطرح عند المئه و91 همم ريال كان
همم بيخصم ب 9% عن اغ السعر يوم الخميس
فبالتالي عند الافتتاح البارحه شهد سهم
تداول انخفاضا واغلق قرابه سعر الطرح
الاخير عند ال 190 ريال لكن الملفت
استمرار التراجعات في جلسه اليوم على سهم
تداول الى ما دون ال 180 ريال ايضا من بين
الاكثر انخفاضا الان سهم تداول سته في
المئه من التراجعات بعد انخفاضات البارحه
بقرابه التسعه او ال 10 في المئه الراجحي
الاهلي كذلك على تراجعات سمعنا الراجحي
طبعا يعلن عن اصدار همم صكوك بقيمه 10
مليار ريال ثابت خمسه ونصف النقطه المئويه
طبعا نعرف الراجحي تحديدا همم التوسع
الهائل والكبير في محفظه الاقراض خصوصا
للافراد وخصوصا للرهونات العقاريه ما
يستدعي جذب اموال اضافيه اما عبر الودائع
او عبر اصدار السندات لتمويل هذا التوسع
في محفظه الاقراض الفرنسي ايضا يع عن
برنامج همم اصدار السندات مقومه بالدولار
في نفس الاطار تقريبا ساعه متراجع ب 1.5
النقطه المئويه في دبي نتابع طبعا حركه
سهم دي اف ام مرتفع باكثر من اربعه في
المئه 4.5% من الارتفاعات اعمار متراجعه
بواحد في المئه ومن المرتقب باعلان عن
النتائج اعمار للربع الثالث لاحقا بعد جرس
الاغلاق في ابو ظبي نشهد المكاسب معظم
الاسهم في ابو ظبي على ارتفاعات موت بلاي
على ارتفاع وهمم
الفضاء ايضا على ارتفاع اتش سي متراجعه
بعض الشيء
والحديث بانه هناك 11 او 11 اكتئاب همم
في سوق ابو ظبي من الان وحتى نهايه العام
المقبل هذه كانت وقفتنا مع الاسواق نعود
الان مجددا اليك عادي شكرا
[موسيقى]
رغم طي الحزبين الكرديين الرئيسيين في
كردستان العراق صفحه خلافته ما على
المناصب الاتحاديه بعد اعلان التشكيل
الحكومه ان هناك نقاط الخلافي لا تزال على
لقبرزها الانتخابات البرلمانيه في الاقليم
بالاضافه الى ملفات النفط والحدود
الخلافات بين الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
وخصميه الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني تتجه
نحو الصعيد اشد السياسيه وامنيا في اقليم
كردستان العراق في غياب تاما لوسطا ما
يجعل الوضع يسير نحو صراع مفتوح دفع ببعض
الاكراد للقول انه تهديد الاقليم الذي
يتمتع بحكم ذاتي ملفات كثيره عالقه بين
الحزبين الرئيسيين ابرزها الانتخابات
البرلمانيه في الاقليم التي تهدد بتصعيد
الصراع داخل البيت الكردي منها كيفيه
الوصول الى قانون الانتخابات يضمن تكافؤ
الفرص المشاركه الحقيقيه وتحديث سجل
الناخبين وكل ما يتعلق بالمكونات الاخرى
وايضا ما يخص المفوضيه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في الاقليم
الدكتور برهام صالح رئيس الجمهوريه كان
سببا في هذه الخلافات او تطور هذه
الخلافات ان كان هناك تطو الخلافات وكانت
هناك شده بسبب شده الخطاب الاعلامي من
الاتحاد الوطني تجاه الحزب الديمقراطي
فهذا بسبب الانتقادات التي وجهت للاتحاد
الوطني لكردستاني الملفات العالقه بين
الحزبين لا تخص شقه الانتخابات فحسب بل
تشمل الطاقه وانعكاسها على حياه المواطن
الكردي وملف المال والخلاف على توزيع
الثروات والايرادات في اقليم كردستان على
جميع المحافظات
متعدده كثيرا هناك مختلفه الاتحاد يختلف
عن وجهه نظري عن الحزب الديمقرا لكل
الثاني لما يتعلق بقضيه اداره الحكم نحن
نبحث عن نقاط مختلفه عن ما يبحث عن الحزب
الديناص لكن بالتالي يبحث عن تواصل يبحث
عن نقاط ايجابيه يجب ان لا تستمر بعض
الملفات الصغيره التي تجزء البيت الكردي
على الاصطدام بين القوتين السياسيين يخص
ايضا موضوع ورقه عمل مشتركه مع الورقه
الاتحاديه تتعلق بجميع الملفات التي تهمه
اقليم كردستان العراق والملف الاتحادي
فضلا عن الخلافات حول الامن والحدود
والنفط مع بغداد والتي اوصلت التوتر
بينهما لصدام محتمل
بلال البوجديني العربيه
بشاميه اعلان السلطات مؤخرا تخفيف بعض
القواعد صارمه التي فرضها لمواجهه انتشار
فايروس
الى مركز الحجر الصحي سمحوا له بالعوده
الى المنزل في اليوم الخامس عندما تم
الاعلان عن لوائح الجديده اعتقد ان لوائح
جيده وكما ترون لا يوجد الكثير من الاشخاص
المصابين بالفعل اعتقد ان لوائح مفيده
لحياه الناس
يمه
ضروريه ومع ذلك لا يجب بالضروره ان تكون
صارمه الى هذا الحد على الرغم من تخفيف
اجراءات الرقابه الان فمن المحتمل ان تظل
المجتمعات المحليه والمقاطعات لديها
تدابير صارمه لذلك الان لا استطيع ان اشرح
حقا بان السياسه المتبعه اتجاهك قد تم
تخفيفها
بهذا الخبر العاجل وزير الداخليه نرفضه
وتعازي الولايات المتحده في ضحايا هجوم
اسطنبول هذا الهجوم الذي نفذته وقفه
الداخليه التركيه همم سوريا كما اشار
مراسلنا قبل قليل زيدان نذهب الى عناوين
سريعه
قتلوا جرحى بقصف صاروخين للحرس الثوري
الايرانيه على مواقع في اربيل وسليمانيه
شمال العراق
تركيا توقف 46 مشتبه من فيجاري تقسيمها
وزير الداخليه يحمل حزب العمال
الكردستانيه المسؤوليه
العربيه ترصد معاناه سكان كيب بسبب انقطاع
الكهرباء جراء القصف الروسي للمنى التحتيه
شكرا جزيلا الى اللقاء
[تصفيق]